going to go with the same action with  rondo coming off the screen and roll by  davis  rondo makes his move drives again back  to davis davis for three  bang anthony davis from downtown  and the lakers take a nine point lead  timeout miami  22 points now for davis his second  three-pointer  and la with some comfort room right now  [Applause]  big buckets by the lakers down the  stretch back-to-back plays they put the  ball in the hands of rondo  you say why it's because i can make sure  that i'm going to get a quality look  he's going to make the proper decision  the first time  drives the second time hands it off to  anthony davis  and lebron james appreciating the work  of his teammates  rondo made that a